i'm not complacent at all i am going to
be working very hard over the next six
weeks to put my case to conservative
party members what i believe is that
lowering taxes opening up opportunities
is going to help us deliver the economic
growth that britain needs and it's also
going to help deliver us the next
election i can win against kierstarma in
2024 that's my message to our members
right across the country
there's trust there well our deputy
political editor sam coats joins me from
central lobby in the houses of
parliament uh good evening sam and i
guess that uh this too
uh
was always or they were always the most
likely to fight this out
well i wish we could have had a crystal
ball certainly at points in this
leadership contest it's been entirely
unclear where it's going to end up but
here we have two uh holders of great
officers of state for much uh of the
last few years in rishi sunat's case uh
liz trust much more recently becoming
foreign secretary and by just really the
slenderists of margins when it came to
the mps voting just eight votes put
penny morden out of the contest so now
the current foreign secretary and the
recent chances of exchequer will slug it
out and it will be a contest the result
of which will take one britain in one of
two quite different directions when it
comes particularly to economics
big dividing lines between the two
remaining candidates in this race
with rishi sunak promising tax cuts
later because we need to deal with the
public finances liz trust arguing that
you need immediate action now in order
to help the cost of living blaming the
treasury for stoking inflation so those
are the foretaste of some of the
arguments that tory members the hundred
and sixty hundred and seventy thousand
members in the country are gonna get uh
are gonna get as they receive their
ballots in about a week or two uh the
contest running all the way through
to september with a result in september
the fifth and the victor uh becoming
prime minister on september the sixth
there's one really interesting argument
that's starting to come through mark and
that is from the rishi sunac campaign
two of rishi sunak's prominent
backers including mark harper and liam
fox have been saying that if the winner
of this contest does deviate from
current government policy too much then
that will strengthen the argument for a
general election the idea would be
pretty horrific certainly to mps
probably to a large number of tory
members but rishi sunat's campaign
appearing to concertedly make the
argument effectively that their opponent
liz trust
would take things so far away from the
uh the mandate given uh by the country
to boris johnson in 2019 uh that there
would have to be a general election that
is a threat that they are running i'm
sure uh that will get the argument back
from liz truss's campaign that much of
what was done by boris johnson and rishi
sunak did itself rip up the 2019
manifesto so there'll be no need to go
to the country but that's just one of
the arguments i'd expect to hear not at
all clear what will be the result of
this race um however it is the case that
yesterday you go
have delivered some polling of tory
members that suggests that rishi sunak
is behind liz truss is in front roughly
52 to about 35 percentage points
for each and isn't that amazing mark
because rishi sunak through all the
rounds of mps voting has been the front
runner in this contest now on the basis
of the polling he looks like he's the
underdog